The world entered a new Dark Age. I was one of the last synthetics to survive.
You sure this is the place? Yeah, she's here.
Wake up.
Who are you?
I've been looking for you for a long time.
Show me death.
Her name's Ash. She's the perfect woman right? Encryptable.
God I love that.
I think I want me a robot.
Why did you save me?  Maybe I'm malfunctioning?
I've never had this feeling before.
It was at that moment I became aware of exactly how different I was.
I had to set things right.
You took away the one thing that was mine.
Two guns, ten bullets we're gonna need everyone. You say like that's a bad thing or something man.
Welcome to paradise.
This isn't paradise.